hey guys it's Amanda Leeds here I'm
Samuels wife and we are in Doncaster
today and up north near my home town of
Leeds we've just purchased the house
here it's a semi-detached house that
we're gonna be converting into two flats
and Samuels giving me free reign on this
I was just at home with the kids and I
was thinking I want to do something
that's a bit exciting he was like hey
we've just bought this house
take it run with it do what you want so
that's what I'm gonna be documenting and
showing you guys my name is Amanda I
haven't spoken to you yet but I'm
Samuels wife and I'm gonna be in the
area today so I was looking to come and
pick up the keys for 74 once were throat
so I'd get him to send an email because
he's actually doing some trained and I
think you'll be able to talk on the
phone but emails with your name here is
why so I've just collected the keys
today and it's actually a nice day
because it's been raining a lot lately
just to let you know a little bit about
me I used to be a quantity surveyor and
I trained in Leeds and that was my
profession and when I got my - Samuel
I left my job and then I started working
in the property business with him I did
a lots and lots of conversions of single
at houses into HMOs on this one this is
a little bit out of my comfort zone
because I've never done this personally
and so we're going to be splitting this
house into two and flats and so it's a
little bit new and but I'm really really
really excited and raring to go but I
haven't seen the property
quite excited to see what its gonna be
like but here we've got the keys and
we're gonna head down now so that's good
right so we've just arrived at the
property now and it looks like a nice
nice area busy street I can see this
buses going past meaning that there's a
good transport links into and the center
so that's good our intention for the
property is to convert it from the one
house into two separate flats and and
rent it out with the intention of
refinancing it to pull our money back
out it looks it looks good from the
outside so let's see what it's like
inside first time lucky
Wow
[Applause]
this looks pretty good it looks like
it's been done up already which is nice
really good condition perfect condition
actually you could have someone move in
straight away it's a nice living room
nice fire makes it homely fit of
gardening needed but that's always
expected with a new property it's just
so good I can't find fault in this this
is perfect kitchen nice kitchen
really really nice obviously newly done
as well good condition looks like a new
appliance
okay the powers off sir I think there's
no electric because this looks like one
of those prepaid meters it says zero
pounds so that would explain why there's
no power so I can't actually test the
power in the house because the electrics
not on so I'm gonna have to sort that
out but I am actually thinking because
it's gonna be two separate properties at
the moment this obviously just serves
this whole house and so the
electrician's gonna have to figure yeah
I don't know how they do it but having a
new one upstairs probably updating this
one I don't really know but that's gonna
be something that's gonna have to happen
as well as the boiler as well and I
don't know if you'd need two boilers for
the two different flats but that's what
will get the people in for two to let me
know I'll see if the waters running
anyway even if I can't get it hot
is running the pressure looks a bit
lower turned it all the way and it's
coming out quite slowly a bit better on
the cold yeah that'll probably just need
to be looked at I think it looks as
those a bit of damp and the paint's
peeling off the wall here so I'm not
sure what's cause that really I think
that's something that we'll definitely
have to have looked at because it
doesn't look good and we want to get to
the root of the problem and force it oh
my goodness this is the downstairs
bathroom and hello I can see inside they
witness it you might've met yourself
with a shower and someone's just like
watching it that's obviously gonna have
to change cuz that's a bit awkward
yeah great door not nice bathroom if I
think this roof is the most
disappointing room of the house really
because I mean on the description it
says that everything was done up and it
was perfect really and ready to go and
when I came in I did think that you
could let this out like that but this
room just lit lets it all down really
it's not completed it's not really a
great finish it doesn't look actually
like it's been newly retitled or
anything so I think with this room would
probably just change the bathroom and
just modernize it these tiles not that
attractive if you ask me but there's
also a bit of an seems to be bit of damp
as well on this wall so it's an outside
wall so it could be that there's
something on the outside possibly that
firms caused this to come through but
yeah it doesn't look great really so
that's another thing as well that's
gonna have to be paid attention we're
thinking of having the downstairs as
flat one and the upstairs are flat too
I'm not actually sure how it's gonna be
reconfigured to have an entrance for
this am top flat here ideally it would
be nice to do you know to walk in and
this be the entrance in but there
obviously isn't a door there at the
moment so I don't really know how what
the build is going to propose but it
would be nice if you could have a door
here and then just come and then this is
your entrance and yeah
enter the flat here so I'm not I'm not
too sure how that's going to work but
I'm really interested to see what what
proposals are made by the Builder okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
notice that there isn't a new carpet in
the other room it'd probably be worth
just changing the carpet some of this in
some of the rooms they've changed some
carpets but not I think it'd be good if
it all matched even though so this is
what we'd make into the kitchen of this
flat interesting because I can't
visualize it and see it yet as a kitchen
it would be really weird but there's the
bathroom just next door so there's water
easily accessible and the kitchen
downstairs is literally just below here
so I'm sure they'll be able to pull up
whatever I don't know of connections
that they need but this is totally
different
I mean a living room into a bedroom easy
but a bedroom into a kitchen I can't
wait to see how that happens so this one
would be the a one bed one bedroom
laughs nice bathroom in comparison to
the other bathroom this one looks way
better and they've obviously done work
in this one it's got a nice towel
radiator down the side it's obviously
been newly tiled nice tiling it looks
really decent so I don't think there's
much to do in here really but something
else that I noticed downstairs as well
but the smoke heads there's no there's
no heads on these detectives not sure
why and like this light fitting is
broken as well so there's little little
things to be fixed but I mean in the
grand scheme of things I mean walking
into a house for the first time this is
probably the least amount of work I've
ever seen me doing when you've just
purchased the house but obviously now
we're gonna mess it up a little bit when
converting it but it's gonna get ugly to
get good again so it's all dirty so I
obviously can't view the roof but I can
actually see the roof of this little bit
on this house I think it might have been
an extension done at some point the roof
actually looks like it's in good
condition it doesn't look in a bad way
at all as well as the gutters there is a
rain pipe though that seems to have
fallen I think it was attached and just
here so that will need to be repaired by
the looks of it but just generally
speaking the roof looks good
so I don't think the way any any major
works there hmm oh wow hey what I've
always wanted a mirror in the garden
it's a really good garden nice big size
hey I think it'll look really good once
all the grasses curtain so something
that I've noticed and when we were
upstairs looking out is that the
neighboring properties have actually put
in a gate and they've got a drive for
two cars but you know so you can have
access this house is actually on a main
road so and you can't park right outside
so it would be good and it would add
something different and nice to this
house if you can actually come in
through the back Park up and then enter
the property that way so I think that's
something that I'll be telling the
Builder to to plan in with the works so
what really really excites me about this
property is the fact that we managed to
get a really good deal on it so you can
see here that this house was on the
market for 99 950 and the previous owner
had actually purchased it for ninety
five thousand pounds back in 2016 he did
it up to this standard hoping to sell it
for more and it just never sold he put
it on the market for 99 950 we came
along and then negotiated the price down
to 94 thousand and that's how much we
purchased it for so we saved five
thousand nine hundred and fifty pounds
just by asking and negotiating what's
even more exciting about that is the
fact that next door sold for one hundred
and twenty one thousand pounds just last
year in May 2018 so it just shows how
much value this house probably is worth
so that's all for today my next steps
are going to be getting the tip for the
council getting permission and to
actually do the works and in the next
video you're going to see me meeting the
Builder and getting those figures so we
know exactly how much it costs to change
a house like that into two so if you're
interested in seeing my journey and how
I get on with converting this property
but don't forget to Like and subscribe
to this channel thanks for watching see
you in the next one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]